this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description get 20% off their annual
premium subscription imagine the perfect
cattle grazing pasture blue skies green
grass shared by everyone of course it
can still only support so many cows if
the farmers were smart they'd figure out
how many and divide that among them but
that's a big if because the incentives
are all wrong
more likely everyone would act in their
own best interest bringing more and more
cows until they destroyed the land and
no one could use it this is the tragedy
of the Commons when resources are shared
but limited people will act selfishly
and ruin it for everyone
it happens in public parks traffic and
fishing but sometimes the opposite
happens and that's the story of patents
instead of land
it's ideas and the problem is not that
everything is shared it's that nothing
is big companies claim everything they
lay their eyes on they patent the
process of making decisions
rounding rectangles even if you can
believe it filing patents you name it
someone technically owns it maybe you
don't plan on using it but at least you
can stop your competitors and what's a
few thousand dollars in filing fees to a
company making 265 billion a year but
all this ownership leaves little room
for innovation just imagine how hard it
would be to design a new smartphone
today without violating anyone's patents
good luck
even if you could somehow figure out
which ones you needed to license which
is already a stretch it would simply be
far too expensive we think of invention
as a sudden flash of inspiration but
usually big ideas are just one
improvement on the last or some new
combination smartphones for example are
a bunch of different ideas put together
and I mean a bunch Google's chief legal
officer says they might be susceptible
to as many as a quarter million patent
claims that's a
mess all of this means that patents can
be not just ineffective but actually
counterproductive so what's the solution
how can we encourage innovation in a way
that you know actually works there are
two ways to look at patents first as a
right creating things takes time and
effort if you paint a picture or write a
story it belongs to you so why should
inventions be any different physically
or otherwise no one wants to be stolen
from this is why we use the term
intellectual property it's no different
than a house or a car which I'd argue is
kind of true a patent can be bought sold
licensed or abandoned but if ideas are
simply property the inventor of a
life-saving drug could just decide not
to share it and if companies deserve
monopolies over their creations or stuck
with the system we have sure in theory
we could adjust it shorten the length of
patents from twenty to ten or five or
even two years and patent trolls or be
more selective about which patents are
approved all of these would be a huge
help
but they wouldn't solve the fundamental
problem to do that we need to view them
not as a right but a trade you and I
promise to give companies a temporary
monopoly and they invest the time and
money to make the products we want but
were being ripped off were often giving
a monopoly when a company would have
made their product anyway in other words
or trading a lot for really nothing in
return would Apple stopped making
iPhones if they couldn't file patents
they might make less money but they'd
almost certainly still be profitable
even with copycats they could stand out
with things like better engineering
talent and marketing how do we know this
because it's already true Xiaomi makes
every attempt to replicate products like
the iPhone but I'd say Apple is still
doing ok or look at Lego whose patents
expired in 2011 but still makes billions
of dollars if anything losing them made
the company more in
of ativ by giving it better competition
of course this isn't always true a
pharmaceutical company for example may
truly need patents to protect its
investment but the goal is to give them
just enough incentive and not a dollar
more and that exact amount varies by
industry which brings us to the
wonderful world of software patents from
the outside you may not think it's any
different an invention is an invention
whether it's made of gears or ones and
zeros but you'd be wrong with software
the problems are ten times worse they
account for 75% of all troll lawsuits
and are twice as likely to be litigated
here's the difference a physical
invention can easily be described as its
parts a ballpoint pen for example can be
patented as a tube an ink reservoir and
a rotating ball but a digital one of
course is made of code and because there
are many ways to program the same
function it wouldn't make sense to
patent specific lines of code someone
could just slightly change it and
besides that's already protected by
copyright so instead software patents
usually describe less a process or
method and more an idea or function
that's the difference between patenting
toy bricks which stack using cylindrical
grooves and the idea of connecting two
objects the latter sounds ridiculous
no one should own such a basic concept
but it happens all the time in software
the other difference is that unlike say
pharmaceuticals software development is
dirt cheap
because nothing is manufactured there's
no limit to its scale when Instagram was
bought by Facebook for a billion dollars
it employed only 13 people and whatsapp
had 55 when it was bought for twenty
billion
what matters is speed a brand new
software startup can beat the biggest
companies on the planet if it moves fast
enough which means by the time a patent
is granted it may no longer be relevant
compare this with government whose
strength is being slow and methodical
and you can see why it doesn't make so
well with tech so if patents are
really a trade and different industries
require different incentives it only
makes sense to negotiate individually
why should the inventor of a Buy Now
button be granted just as long a
monopoly as the creator of a drug that
took years and years of research the
solution is a prize system where the
first inventor gets a check not a
monopoly this way companies compete
lower prices and make their products
more accessible not in 20 years when
their patent expires but today many new
companies would finally have a fighting
chance and as a nice cherry on top
patent trolls would be eliminated
overnight of course there are some
challenges we need a system for
determining what kind of inventions
require a prize and that money would
have to come from somewhere which
probably means your favorite higher
taxes again it's not perfect but it need
only be 1% better than what we have and
that's already a pretty low bar so if
such a simple solution exists why aren't
we using it for one because the
companies that benefit most from patents
are the ones with money to lobby for
them and because many people just don't
know much about economics there just
isn't much awareness but patents and the
stock market are really economic games
and with today's sponsor brilliant you
can learn the hidden mathematical rules
to better understand them
it teaches concepts like game theory
economic statistics and tons of other
topics on science math and computer
science unlike your professor brilliant
understands that people learn by doing
not just memorizing over and over again
so you'll solve riddles play with graphs
and answer challenges as you progress
through the lessons to get started or
dive deeper into the world of math
science and technology go to brilliant
org slash poly matter and sign up today
for free the first 200 people to use
that link will also get 20% off at the
annual premium subscription thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video and
as always to you for listening